what did you take from the set with each
of you take me which is the one thing
you kept or may be many things did you
steal oh my god you what did you steal
it's oh these are like made of velcro
what tomorrow's the big premiere he'll
be there Kevin have you got a peek at
Leslie's dress I am not seeing I want to
see it when the whole shebang is is uh
up and going yeah that drama were Leslie
couldn't find a designer to help her
with a dress I'm mad as hell well we're
actually kind of glad it happened
because it brought her together with
designer Christian Siriano and we cannot
wait to see what he's got planned for
tomorrow's big premiere there's only one
person whose outfit matters I'm not tell
anything you're not I'm not something or
I said it black okay whatever oh really
no I'm not all right now now huh
let's go let's go Oh the ladies are of
course giving this reboot their own
twist including some unexpected comedy
from chris hemsworth we hear he's got a
surprise at the end of the movie don't
listen what was it like when he starts
dancing what are you guys standing on
the side roaring with laughter it's I
mean everything everything about it was
just like it kept getting cooler and
more surprising and when you're in a big
action movies you get to have your own
action figures what's it like when you
first get your action figure and you
start to play with it like what do you
do with your well that's far I haven't
sat around SAT around a pig tails but uh
it's pretty crazy in wild of course
playing a Ghostbuster doesn't really
mean you believe in ghosts or does it do
you believe in ghosts I do I know enough
to know I don't know I don't believe
that anybody has it walked into a room
or been somewhere where they're just
like it was weird